distinguished guests the president of
the United States accompanied by founder
of the Center for Rural Enterprise and
environmental justice Catherine Coleman
flowers
[Music]
thank you
good afternoon
my name is Catherine Coleman flowers
founder of the Center for Rural
Enterprise and environmental justice
I am thrilled to be here alongside
friends Advocates and fellow members of
The White House environmental justice
advisory Council I am a country girl
from Lowndes County Alabama
where I learned important lessons about
democracy and voting for years
Wastewater infrastructure for many
families there has been failing or
non-existent not unlike rural
communities Nationwide
now with the help of this white house
we're fixing that
using principles of democracy one person
or a small group of rural folk can
invest can advance the Quest for
environmental justice
we are here because President Biden
listened since the campaign the
president has consistently demonstrated
his commitment to environmental justice
for rural and urban communities
in his first days in office the
president created our advisory Council
bringing the voices of communities into
federal policy making
he believes that every child deserves a
safe and healthy Community with clean
air to breathe clean water to drink
healthy foods to eat and access to parts
three days ago
I had the pleasure of welcoming the
newest member of my family
my granddaughter Halo Olivia
for my grandchildren's future and for
generations to come I am grateful that
President Biden is putting climate and
environmental justice at the center of
the conversation
with that it is my honor to introduce
the president of the United States Joe
Biden
thank you
thank you thank you Catherine I
appreciate that very much
and I'm sure you all love sitting in the
sun
here but it could be worse it could be
raining
it's a beautiful day as that old
Treasures to go beautiful day in the
neighborhood and this beautiful excuse
me I'm putting on my sunglasses so I can
see
all right
as I've told my distinguished friend
from Massachusetts a good friend Senator
Markey that uh it's really very very
dull when after all these years in
public life you're known for two things
Ray-Ban sunglasses and chocolate chip
ice cream
a very dull president but uh
look uh
you're a great leader
uh Catherine I really mean it and just
name the most name one of the most
influential people
of the Year Time Magazine
being
a
grandparents second time around that's
the best of the jobs right
yeah well look congratulations to your
granddaughter she can be looking up to
you for a long time and I thank everyone
for joining us here today EPA
administrator Reagan has done a hell of
a heck of a job for us for a long time
and I kid her all the time had she been
born in the United States instead of
Canada she'd be the president standing
here Jennifer granholm my secretary of
state
you're doing a great job here
the chair of the White House Council on
Environmental Quality Brenda where's the
mall over there
[Applause]
members of Congress
work on this issue every day or
Champions environmental justice let's
get something straight none of this
would have happened without you guys
in fact
look stand up and I'm on the a war hero
is not going to be able to stand up
because she's in his wheelchair but
everybody else please stand up
[Music]
and uh I'd also want to mention a member
who can't be here today Congressman an
old friend Don McEachern a lifelong
Fighter for environmental justice
we fall white Kel for every one of the
things we're going to talk about today I
want to thank all you Advocates and
Community leaders including members of
The White House environmental justice
advisory Council many of whom have been
working in this year for a long time and
persuading those in power to pay
attention pay attention to make this a
priority to care
look what you know what you do matters
it matters a great deal I ask all of you
in the council to stand up and be
recognized some couldn't be here today
I mean a thank you
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
Earth day is tomorrow a chance to
reflect on the national wonders of our
nation and our planet but we have to do
a great deal more than just reflect
we have to commit ourselves to action
will we step up to our Ambitions will we
stand together to meet the great
challenges we have will we preserve our
planet for future Generations history is
going to judge us by how we answer these
questions and that's not hyperbole
that's a fact and today I hope the
answer is going to be allowed and clear
yes yes we're committed to following the
signs yes we're determined to strength
and the Ambitions and that our Ambitions
and actions and yes we will include
communities that have been denied basic
security basic dignity that comes from
clean air having clean air clean water
and clean energy jobs and environmental
justice and folks like you environmental
issues have been close to my heart for a
long time
you know it was uh one of the first
people to introduce a climate bill I did
back in 1986.
you're part of it was because I grew up
and maybe there's one Delaware and who
knows where Claymont Delaware is I grew
up in
oh all right
well I grew up in Claymont Delaware
which is just on the Pennsylvania line
the time I was growing up there in a
area called Brookview Apartments there
were more oil refineries in that neck of
the woods in that south east corner of
Pennsylvania then in Houston Texas and I
went to school about a half quarter mile
a mile up the road on the thing called
the Philadelphia plate
and mom used to drive us up because it
was a very busy highway and to drop us
off and and on those days early on when
there'd be the first Frost you turn on
the windshield wipers not a joke and to
be an oil slick on the window
literally an oil slick on the front
windshield and how many folks across the
country have had similar experiences you
know we know Public Health impacts of
toxins and air and water and there's
real real effects so I think is one of
the reasons I had childhood asthma so
many people in that area we had one of
the highest cancer rates in the nation
in that part of Delaware for the longest
time
that's why when I was running for
president I made it a priority to meet
with the environmental with
environmental justice leaders I remember
one conversation we had in the summer of
their stories were Unforgettable people
living near factories seeing the paint
on their cars literally peel off because
the air was so corrosive imagine being a
parent scared to death about what the
air and rain was going to do to your
kids
landfills and garbage incentives located
right in the middle of communities
drinking water contaminated by radon and
arsenic this kind of inequity and
Injustice goes against everything we
stand for as a nation but it continues
to exist
so when I was elected president with
Kamala and her partnership we vowed to
take action of the most ambitious
climate environmental justice agenda in
American history and that's exactly what
we did with your support
on day one of my presidency we re-enter
the power we re-entered the Paris
agreement because the United States
should lead the world in fighting the
climate presence
yesterday I convened the major economic
Forum on on Zoom comprised the world
leaders leading emitters to accelerate
progress and help poor countries and
communities deal with the impacts of
climate change and I announced that I'm
going to ask Congress for 500 million
dollars to protect the Amazon
deforestation and get other countries to
do Senate the same
it's an Irreplaceable resource that the
whole planet depends on
but to lead the world we have to start
here at home
my first week as president I signed an
executive order directing my
Administration to take sweeping action
to tackle a climate crisis and we set a
historic goal
to direct 40 percent to assuming direct
40 percent of the overall benefits of
all federal investment in climate change
to clean air clean water clean Transit
and more to communities that are
disproportionately impacted by
environmental degradation and with your
support we're living up to that pledge
through our just for justice 40
initiative
be passed
we passed the bipartisan infrastructure
law to modernize our roads Bridges ports
airports and so much more replacing
every single lead pipe in America
because we think everyone should be able
to turn on a faucet at home or the 400
000 schools and drink clean water
property school districts across the
country electify their school buses so
kids don't have to breathe polluted air
from diesel exhaust
across Appalachian to Great Plains for
plugging the so-called orphan Wells
which emit methane which is
significantly more dangerous and toxic
than than anything else that comes out
of the ground more dangerous gases
poisoning air and water in rural
communities we're delivering clean water
and clean sanitation to millions of
families we're cleaning up toxic
pollution including brownfields and
Superfund sites which have been a blight
on communities for decades
the vice president wanted to be here
today but she's in Florida announcing
Investments we're making in
strengthening infrastructure in coastal
areas that are vulnerable to storms but
together together we pass the inflation
reduction act which makes the most
significant investment in dealing with
climate change ever anywhere in the
history of the world literally not
particularly
370 billion dollar investment which will
reduce annual carbon emissions by 1
billion tons in 230 2030. and folks for
example it offers Working Families a
thousand dollars a year in savings for
pride and rebates for to buy new
efficient appliances weatherize their
homes get tax credits for purchasing
heat pumps and rooftop solar energy
efficient ovens dryers and so much more
provides tax credits for electric
vehicles new and used because we're
convinced we convince the auto companies
on this lawn out here a year and a half
ago to move to all electric vehicles in
the near term
it's a gigantic Game Changer and that's
not all inflation reduction act also is
the most significant law in U.S history
when it comes to environmental justice
here's just one example air pollution
around ports folks who live near ports
no air pollution can be extreme because
all trucks and all the vehicles moving
Goods in and out of ports and on the
backs of ship are polluting the air
significantly well the inflation
reduction act includes major investments
in adopting clean heavy duty trucks and
clean Port equipment and folks it's
going to take make a real difference for
families who live near those ports we're
investing
we're invested in air quality centers in
communities near factories so people who
live near them can know what the risk is
and how safe the air is because we know
historically Red Line communities are
literally hotter because there's more
pavement fewer trees so we're planting
millions of new trees to cool down our
city streets and we're also making major
investments in clean energy in
disadvantaged communities to lower
energy costs and create good paying jobs
Brenda was recently in Houston where
we're building a solar farm on the site
of a former landfill right in the middle
of a neighborhood another example of
what's good for the environment is also
good for job Brenda thank you
and this these are the kinds of projects
we're funding all across the country in
urban Rural and suburban and tribal
communities and then last year Jill and
I reignited the cancer moonshot and
cancer as we know it
it's a whole government effort and one
of our top priorities to better
understand and prevent environmental
intoxic exposures
if we do that we know we know we can
save and extend millions of lives look
this is about People's Health
it's about the health of our communities
it's ultimately about the future of our
planet
just since I become president I've flown
over literally thousands of acres of
land burned flat by Wildfire because of
environmental changes
more acreage burn to the ground that
I've witnessed from a helicopter in the
last 19 months then then are in the
entire state of Maryland as if the
entire state of Maryland burned to the
ground
I've seen too many communities turn to
Rubble by storms that are growing more
frequent and ferocious
and it's a existential threat to our
nation and literally to the world
I wish I could say that everyone saw it
that way
but just this past week we heard speaker
McCarthy and the mag this is not your
father's Republican Party
the Maggie republicans in Congress want
to repeal climate Provisions in the
inflation reduction Act
they'd rather threaten to default on the
U.S economy then get rid or get rid of
some 30 billion dollars in taxpayer
subsidies rather than get rid of 30
billion dollars taxpayer subsidies to an
oil industry that made 200 billion
dollars last year
imagine making that choice
imagine seeing all this happen the
wildfires the storms the floods
and doing nothing about it nothing about
it
imagine taking all these clean energy
jobs away from working class folks all
across America
imagine turning your back on all those
moms and dads living in towns poisoned
by pollution and telling them sorry
you're on your own
we can't let that happen I mean really
can't let that happen that's why this
executive order in my view is so
important and here are some of the
things this executive order will do
under this order
environmental justice will become the
responsibility of every single federal
agency I mean every single federal
agency
that means every Federal agency must
take into account environmental and
health impacts on communities and the
work to prevent those negative impacts
environmental justice will be the
mission of the entire government woven
directly into
how we work with State local tribal and
territorial governments
this is an order directs the federal
agencies to address gaps in science and
technology for example
there's a lot we still don't know about
the quality of people's Wastewater or
the air they're breathing there's still
a lot we don't know about the cumulative
impacts of pollution on people's health
we need to learn more so we can serve
those communities better and help the
world overall
and this executive order
this executive order creates a new
office of environmental justice and new
role for the chief environmental justice
officer they're going to coordinate
they will coordinate all our efforts
across government to make sure we're
delivering the greatest possible
benefits to people's lives this
executive order honors and builds on
Decades of work including by many of you
are here today in the private as well as
public sector
two years
in two years are making real progress in
the most ambitious environmental justice
agenda in history
with this executive order we'll go even
further
let me close with a story
last January the vice president went to
Atlanta to speak to a group of four
historical black colleges and
universities about voting rights
and and on the flight home
I read an article about the crisis in in
Lowndes County we just heard about
Alabama just outside of Selma
were more than 40 percent
of the major black president majority
black residents lack access to clean
sanitation system 40 percent
the article described a local leader who
said without Federal intervention we
would have never had voting rights
without Federal interventions we will
never have sanitation equality either
well I immediately call my team and said
make sure our help gets down on the
ground to these folks a few months later
administrator Reagan and secretary
vilsack were in my infrastructure
coordinator Mitch Lander we're down in
Alabama announcing a new intensive
initiative to ensure that the poorest
communities in America have access to
clean functioning Wastewater systems
folks
the local leader who I just quoted is
also the one who introduced me Catherine
thank you Catherine a few months later I
went down to Selma walked across the
bridge to Mark the 58th anniversary of
Bloody Sunday my several times I've done
that
a March for the right to vote
but also for all the rights that flow
from the right to vote
including the right to breathe clean air
to drink clean water and to be treated
with dignity to all of you we're making
progress but there's much more to do to
finish the job we just have to remember
who we are we're the United States of
America and there's nothing beyond our
capacity if we work together and we're
like people on this South on this lawn
have done may God bless you all keep it
up now I'm going to sign this executive
order and we're going to get to work
thank you thank you
Charlie
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay
all right folks and thank you
thank you thank you thank you
thank you come on slide in here
desk is hot the pen is
executive order revitalizing our
nation's commitment to environmental
justice for all
great day
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you